can steal it the NBA had to issue
statements saying these women are
stealing companies wait wait we we're
you can get an IUD that's 99.5 effective
you can get birth control if that
doesn't work you can get the Plan B pill
if that doesn't work you can take the
abortion pill if that doesn't work you
can get an abortion up to three months
there is no excuse me I'm just I'm not
disagreeing with you they are outliers
but you're talking about our lives
if you wear a condom properly
99.9
are gonna get the girl pregnant so this
okay no the thing is we're talking about
mandam here in London we're talking
about okay oh you know what the rubber
don't feel though doesn't feel good yeah
okay okay but that's but let's let's
take the condom example okay you can say
you cannot have sex with me unless you
have a condom on yeah that women are in
control of sex we are in control and who
has more power the one who is 41 for
wait who is 4 41 forms of birth control
are the one who has won less more power
let's also think about with societal
pressures when it comes to women no
don't roll your eyes because it's a fact
now but babe these Quantum things are
true because no no these people there's
a lot of people that carry this boosting
things
like it's my Russian action action of
disgusting but it's just true like to be
honest it's not only about pregnancy
here yeah if you don't wear a condom
this you can be called Lydia chlamydia
you can get gonorrhea you can get
anything you know so that's kind of on
you and if you then like some people
they play Russian roulette with this
pill yet
um they literally skip four days and
they're like four pills in and then they
get pregnant then it's then you know
like if I don't choose to keep the child
you know like that's a thing and also
like I feel like a lot of people get
their emotions caught up in this thing
like let's say yeah you're with your
boyfriend you know it's been cheating
and then you get pregnant and then your
emotions get involved you're like oh but
he's so cute on his good days
maybe it could work it's never gonna
work because he's been cheating so or
you know if it's just not the ideal
situation then you as a woman
how much is you cannot like it you still
choose to have the baby even though the
situation is not perfect same with the
condom thing right if a guy comes at
your house you know you're doing your
thing and then it's time to put the
rubber on and you're and you're like oh
I'm in the moment and something happens
that's your body that's you not being
sacred with your body as much as you
dislike it
it's true because you have to deal with
the consequence you just I agree you do
actually have to deal with the
consequence which is very unfortunate
but I think it's
I think of course there is lame when it
comes to women you have made a choice to
have sex without a condom 100 you have
allowed religion or whatever societal
cultural influences affect how you feel
in terms of abortion or contraception or
whatever but I still feel like if you're
having sex with a man and he says I
don't want to have a condom and you're
like you know okay fine I don't want to
have a condom either but he also chose
not to use a Content
can I can I ask you a question I'm gonna
ask you a question okay so say all right
say you have sex and you get pregnant
okay
who who controls who gives birth who
whose choice is that what what after
you're pregnant who whose choice is it
I have a question for you do you know I
need you to answer that question that's
fine I need you to okay yeah women give
birth cool no no no no who's in control
of whether you keep it or give birth
yeah that's fine okay I agree with that
of course you have the baby okay so of
course you're gonna be the one so you
agree that women have more who have
control over who is born a hundred
percent control oh of course okay okay
what's your what's your question and
then I can someone said something about
being selfish wait wait wait bro like if
a woman has 100 control over who or who
gets born right yeah you have no control
of that so yeah I understand so if you
so if a woman gets pregnant yes and and
you want that baby I have no saying that
okay cool and then if you don't want
that baby you still have no say in it
yeah how is that not 100 controlling
selfish no I'm saying if the girl wants
to have the baby right how is that
selfish if she has a baby and she feels
like it's right what if you don't no
because I don't have any control in this
yeah
if you know someone and I'll take all
their responsibilities I'm having sex
with you if I have a baby with you then
I'm gonna take older
you can have to you if you don't want to
you though and she decides to have to
you but my [ __ ] you have sex without a
contact
okay but but the point is we we have
more power yeah we have we so so if we
are going to get more power it comes
with responsibility having more of the
responsibility because the man the men
have one choice condom or no condom we
can't we can't we know when we're
ovulating you know when you're you
should
wait wait and you you are the choice you
get who gets to chew who all right all
right wait who gets to choose whether or
not they're on birth control men or
women women who gets to choose whether
or not we take the plan B men or women
women who gets to choose when if if you
have sex on or off your when you're
ovulating men or women who has the
choice to track their cycle men or women
women who has the choice to get an
abortion women women Okay so
who has the choice to have sex is two
people right as soon as soon as your
um consent into having sex
okay okay yeah okay sex is is
reproduction so from the time that you
lay down with a woman from the time a
woman lies down with a man there's a
possibility that is
listening to what I said no no I hear
what you're saying I do hear what you're
saying but I said women are in control
of who is born yeah men are like who
after I understand that the sex they
both get to pick but after the sex it is
a hundred women are in control yeah but
also but do you not think that the the
guy from the time that he is the woman
he should have the responsibility
I think I think when women have 10
choices we can make to avoid that
situation and men have one there's more
responsibility on us and also I'm saying
a man has responsibility for life
do I do I think men should just shoot
like I've heard some stories where y'all
don't even pull out I'm like you're
crazy
and I do I do I recommend that no but at
the end of the day we have 10 choices
they have one maybe maybe two if you
would close it out so women have more
responsibility that's all you're saying
okay
with all the points you've made yes but
I just want to know what point do we
draw the line and actually say that like
that because let's take an irresponsible
man let's take a baby daddy let's take
Nick Cannon that's that's okay
wait wait wait wait okay okay arguably
irresponsible are you happy okay yeah
okay okay so that's one arguably
sexually irresponsible man that's ten
sexually irresponsible women absolutely
so again it's more on like there are
more sexually irresponsible women than
there are sexually irresponsible men
because you guys might not know this but
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
where the majority of women are sexually
active and there are more STD cases than
ever before yeah that's more out of
wedlock pregnancies than ever before
there's more abortions I actually I'm
not 100 sure I think there's more
abortions than ever before and and so
it's like is it on the men when most of
men aren't sleeping around that much
most men only around 20 percent of men
can really sleep around like that and
then so then it comes back to the women
because who are we picking to sleep with
yeah because also most people
if I took if I know most guys I know
they like to sleep without I feel like
most people let's be honest like to
sleep without condoms right but at the
end of the day
let's say you meet a guy on a party and
you choose to sleep without economy you
don't know what he's been doing he might
have been in London Birmingham Rio de
Janeiro Paris Amsterdam he's been
everywhere and you let him enter that's
not only about you let him maybe getting
pregnant that's about you being
irresponsible with your body and I feel
like a lot of people need to come to
terms with themselves and think you know
what this is my body because at the end
of the day women for example with
chlamydia a lot of women don't know that
they have it let's say yeah you get
chlamydia you don't get checked up often
you might get infertile that's on you
because you chose to let someone enter
your body without a condom that was your
choice and I have a question just just
and ladies hopefully we can be honest
here how many of you have a guy in your
friend zone that you know would date you
and would be a good guy and would be
there raise your hand if you do raise
your hand raise your hand a good guy do
you know what date you take you you
don't have one none no they are smart
they wouldn't date me no none okay okay
yeah three three okay yeah so it's like
no none none can I just touch on what
you said about the about the Russian
roulette with the pill see like I will
only sleep with someone without a condom
unless like I'm kind of with them and
that's that's the thing and I know
they're not with it and if they've been
checked yeah yeah yeah okay but if I
forget my pill like say a one day two
day I don't play Russian Roulette I'll
openly say to him look I forgot my pill
we need to wrap up be careful because
that's my response yeah because I've
also heard these stories where girls
I'm sorry but nothing against women but
this to me sounds so [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
I'm swearing sorry this sounds so weird
in my head where girls lie to baby shop
yeah and they say their own
contraception I'm thinking what are you
doing it's happened to a lot of them I
just don't get it you're literally
playing with fire I have a question for
the men do any as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible